the Sun fire company in Dresden has
developed something remarkable they've
devised a sophisticated process to
create this clear liquid they call blue
crude it's a replacement for crude oil
which can then be turned into synthetic
fuel
near zadig of Sunfire sets out the
advantages of blue crude based gasoline
or diesel not only could it help replace
fossil fuels it could also be carbon
neutral a car powered by our fuel emits
as much co2 and water in its exhaust as
goes into manufacturing the fuel it's a
closed system and that makes it so
environmentally friendly here's how it
works
you take green energy water and the
greenhouse gas co2 this all undergoes
several reactions to produce blue crude
the mixture that's a replacement for
crude oil producing blue crude requires
lots of electricity so it needs to come
from renewable sources Oslo based
entrepreneur Rolf broken-up heard about
Sun fire pretty much by chance and was
intrigued Norway has long been a pioneer
in promoting green energy well when I
saw this an open morning I read this
business paper and I saw this article I
immediately saw the potential for for
producing this in high volumes hearing
over since I'm a hydropower guy that was
the link to it
there are nearly 1,000 hydropower plants
in Norway
just about all the electricity generated
in Norway comes from hydropower it's
also very cheap which is important if
blue crude is to be competitive
electricity accounts for between 40 and
60% of the cost of producing synthetic
fuel
because Norway has plenty of cheap
renewable energy
Ralph broken-up thinks it's the perfect
place to upscale blue crude production
to industrial dimensions in addition we
need also access to carbon dioxide which
could also be expensive for us and there
is also are substantial costs related to
the investments we are making when you
see the plant the poor plant behind me
here we could produce approximately 8
million liters of air diesel
yearly Ralph Bruckner has found a
plentiful source of carbon dioxide a
cement factory at brave Excel west of
Oslo it blasts huge amounts of the
greenhouse gas into the air
Bruckner wants to capture that harmful
carbon dioxide and use it to manufacture
a synthetic fuel based on blue crude
this is a big problem for Norway and we
can use this public I said into our
products and produce approximately 100
million litres of blue crude earlier
which in turn can feed if we use only
that for diesel could be a fuel for
approximately 100,000 cars
I'll bet Albers is head of IP EK the
Institute of product engineering in
Karlsruhe Germany one of his research
areas is vehicle drive systems and the
future of Transportation
he believes that electric vehicles will
not entirely replace those powered by
combustion engines
he says the kind of diesel made from
blue crude looks very promising for one
thing gas stations wouldn't need to be
modified to accommodate it cars wouldn't
need to be modified either standard fuel
tanks and engines would do just fine
developing a sustainable hydrogen based
system will take a long time and a well
thought out strategy but I believe it's
the only way to go the future of
mobility will be converting hydrogen in
various forms into fuel for use in
combustion engines that's the kind of
thing Sun fire likes to hear after years
of development work the firm says it's
time for blue crew to enter the
industrial mainstream near Ziya doug
says there has however been some
resistance the problem is the mental
hurdle some people seem to believe that
if the kind of fuel we're working on is
approved that would be bad for electro
mobility and battery development we
don't agree we believe that both
technologies will be needed and can
coexist but as long as we assume that
one technology will be harmful to the
other it will be very hard for the
underappreciated technology to thrive
Sunfire hopes that once the visionaries
in Norway begin industrial scale
production
critics will be won over by the benefits
of blue crude that would be the
breakthrough Sunfire is hoping for